i didn't even see that's possible i  assumed uh hugh fan would choose this  square for her rook um so  it was impossible to go after white's  pawn there because black's bishop was  trapped in the corner black had to move  that bishop but now there's a there's  tactics there's tricks yeah white is now  attacking that black bishop that black  bishop has no safe squares  huyfan now has to just give up her  bishop if she takes that white pawn  white's rook will slide across one  square and pin that bishop  but if she moves that rook that bishop  from the diagonal hey what is going to  move the rook two squares up and uh well  that's it she resigns about to lose her  bishop who you fan gives up